تطورات ميدانيه والتصريحات روسيه يعرضها
لنا من دنياسك مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
دغير ونكمل الصوره من اوديسا مع منصه
الجزيره عامر لافي لعرض المواقف
الاوكرانيه نور الدين ابدا معك هل من
تفاصيل حول ما تقول بانه قصف تعرض له جسر
في شبه جزيره القرن
جلال الحديث الان من حاكم خرسنا الموالي
لروسيا الذي تحدث عن هذه العمليه يقول بان
القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت ما يقارب من 12
صاروخا وتم تحديد نوعيه هذا الصاروخ يتم
الحديث الان على ان الصاروخ من نوع 12
صاروخا من نوع تم استهدافها تم استهداف
هذا الجسر الرابط ما بين خرسون وشبه جزيره
القرم لحد الساعه الحديث عن الخسائر يبدو
انه لم يسقط اي قتيل او ضحايا كثر هناك
اصابه شخص واحد كان على الجسر اثناء
استهداف احد الصواريخ لهذا الجسر وكذلك
تضرر في الجسر وتضرر في انبوب الغاز الذي
يمر من قرب الجسر ما يتم الحديث عنه هنا
على ان هذه الصواريخ تم اعتراض تسعه منها
واحدى هذه الصواريخ سقط باحدى القرى
المجاوره للجسر ماء ادى الى تضرر احد
المباني المتواجده هناك احد الافراد الذي
كان بالقرب من المبنى لكن اذا ما اردنا
الحديث عسكريا وكيف يتم الحديث هنا عسكريا
عن استهداف هذا الجسر هناك حديث على ان
الجسر الرابط ما بين خرسون وشبهي جزيره
القرم هو جسر ربما قد يستخدم بشكل كبير
لاغراض التنقل المدني ولا يحمل اي اهميه
عسكريه ولا يحمل اي موقع عسكري او دعم
استراتيجي عسكري يمكن ان تعتمد عليه روسيا
اذا النظره الاولى التي يتحدث بها الان
المسؤولون الروس على ان الاستهداف كان
استهدافا مدنيا لكن جلال منذ الصباح ونحن
نتحدث على ان منطقه خرسون تحولت مره اخرى
الى منطقه مواجهات ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه نعني ان
القوات الروسيه تحاول بشكل او باخر الحد
من الضغط الذي كانت تمارسه القوات
الاوكرانيه من اجل السيطره على مزيد من
المسافات فبدات تستهدف تموقع و تمركز
القوات الاوكرانيه ويبدو ان هذا الاستهداف
لهذا الجسر ربما قد يحمل في تناياه هذه
القراءه العسليه العسكريه الضغط على
القوات الروسيه لتخفيف وطاتها في المناطق
مناطق خرسون وعدم التحرك قدما الى الامام
وكذلك محاوله عرقله اي تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه وبكل تاكيد الان نحن في صراع
ما بين القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه
الخط العريض فيه هو استهداف المناطق
الحيويه
المناطقيه المناطق الاستراتيجيه سواء
الموانئ سواء الجسور او عمق المدن لذلك
يمكن ان نقول بان اي هجوم داخل العمق
الروسي عمق الروسي ربما قد يقابله كذلك
هجوم داخل العمق الاوكراني وهو ما تحدثت
عنه روسيا اليوم مباشره عن مجموعه من
الصواريخ المجنحه التي تمت استهدفت العديد
من المواقع الاوكرانيه المهمه على المستوى
العسكري وكذلك ينعكس على طبيعه الميدان من
الشمال الى الجنوب ومحاوله كل طرف ف
سيطرته سعي روسي في الجنوب لمنع القوات
والتقدم قدما وسعي روسي كذلك في الشمال
والشمال الغربي لكسب المزيد من المساحات
لتضييق الخناق على القوات الاوكرانيه في
خركيب لمنع تقدمها الى الداخل الروسي
وكذلك محاوله تطويقها في شمال
الروسي كذلك من اجل لا يتوقف على مدار
الساعه عامر لافي هل الاستهداف جسر في
القرن يبدو كانه رد اوكراني طبيعي على
توسيع دائره الاستهداف الروسيه لمناطق
اوكرانيه
جلال ما دام هذا البحر خلفي هادئ بعيدا عن
السفن التي تمخر عبابه لابد ان نقول بان
حاله التوتر هنا في الجنوب ستستمر هذا
وفقا لما نراه من حال التوتر المستمر
وتبادل القصف وتبادل الهجمات هذا جسر لم
يقصف للمره الاولى وقصف قبل الان
الاوكرانيون في حاله تبادل الهجمات ولا شك
ان هذا رد على القصف الكبير والواسع الذي
طال العديد من المحافظات الاوكرانيه منذ
ليله الامس وحتى فجر هذا اليوم كما ذكرتم
في النشره حوالي سبعين هجوما بالصواريخ
وبالمسيرات استهدف الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تقول القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه بانها
اسقطت 30 من هذه الصواريخ و27 من المسيرات
لكن هناك صواريخ سقط على الارض واستهدفت
العديد ايضا من المناطق الرئيسكي كان قد
تحدث عن مصنع لصناعه محركات الطائرات في
زبروجيا احد المناطق التي استهدفت ايضا
تحدث عن قنبله سقطت في كوبيانس في خار كيف
وقال بان هناك قتلى وجرحى سقطوا جراء سقوط
هذه القنبله على مركز لنقل الدم اليوم
حاكم اخر كيف تحدث عن عدد القتلى والجرحى
وقال بان اثنين من السكان قتل قتل رجل في
الستين من عمره وامراه في الخمسين من
عمرها قتل هناك بالاضافه الى اربع مصابين
ايضا جلال طبعا هناك منطقه مهمه جدا قصفت
وهي كيمنسكي هذه المحافظه التي تقع في
الغرب من اوكرانيا
وحاكم هذه المدينه تحدث عن تضرر العديد من
المناطق السكنيه
والمرافق الحيويه في هذه المدينه لكن
الروس تحدثوا عن استهداف مطار عسكري مهم
جدا ووحد اهم المطارات في هذه المنطقه وهو
مطار ستارا كوستانتينف وهذا المطار تحديدا
تحدث بخصوصه المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
يوري اجماد عندما رد على ما قال بانه
بروباندا روس يه تحدثت عن تدمير كثير
وعشرات من الطائرات في هذا المطار هو يقول
بان هناك بروتوكول معين لدينا الكثير من
المطارات وعندما نشعر بوجود هجوم تبدا هذه
الطائرات بالتحرك
وتخرج من المطار وبالتالي هذه الطائرات لا
تصاب بكثير من الاذى فلنستمع لما قاله
اجنات بخصوص هذا المطار المهم الاستراتيجي
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يتعرض فيها
هذا المطار للهجوم انه القاعده الدائمه
للواء الطيران التكتيكي لكن طيارنا
يتميزون بقدرتهم على التحرك بسرعه ويعرفون
كيفيه مواجهه العدو في هذه الظروف لدينا
عشرات من المطارات العامله على اراضي
الدوله لذلك لن يتمكن العدو من تدمير
طائراتنا فقط الدعايه الروسيه تتحدث عن
تدمير مئات الطائرات في سلاح الجو
الاوكراني
عامر
الدين نفيد شكرا لكما